If you have teenagers or work closely with young people, chances are you've had mystifying conversations like this one. LIT, it means that it's going to be exciting or fun and that you should be there. Like that party is going to be lit. My producer Maggie Penman recently went on a slang-finding mission in Washington DC. She ended up talking to a group of college students from American University. Yeah, Tert is another one.
如果你有十几岁的孩子或与年轻人密切共事，你很可能会进行过这样让人摸不头脑的对话。LIT，意思是这会很刺激、很好玩，你可千万别错过。就像“那个派对会很火爆（lit）”。我的制片人玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）最近去华盛顿特区执行了一项寻找俚语的任务。她最后和美国大学的一群大学生聊了起来。对，“Tert”是另一个词。
Like, but like, I don't know what's Tert. Like, Tert, it's one of those words that you just can't really define. You just have to use it in the context. Tert, it's gonna be lit. Tert is used to describe lit. Yeah. So fun. It'll be lit at 11 p.m. and it'll be turned at 1 a.m. and then it'll be
就像，但是，我不知道什么是 Tert。就像，Tert，它是那种你真的无法定义的词。你只能在语境中使用它。Tert，它会很火（lit）。Tert 是用来形容 lit 的。对。太好玩了。晚上 11 点会很火（lit），凌晨 1 点会很嗨（turned），然后它会
ratchet at 2 a.m. Ratchet? Ratchet. Yeah, ratchet's like, oh my gosh, everybody's sloppy. This isn't fun anymore. This is just ratchet. Young people have always used language
在凌晨 2 点变成乱七八糟（ratchet）。Ratchet？Ratchet。对，ratchet 的意思是，哦天哪，大家都喝得烂醉如泥。这不好玩了。这简直太糟糕了（ratchet）。年轻人总是在使用语言
in new and different ways. And it is pretty much always driven older people. Crazy. Onsleek is usually used in relation to somebody's eyebrows. Yeah, why? Why? Why? Because eyebrows are a big trend right now. If you do great eyebrows, you're like pretty. So that's like the new thing to do. And usually it's an in it came from Instagram. Whenever somebody like I just saw it like five minutes ago on somebody's Instagram,
以新的、不同的方式。而且这几乎总是让老一辈人。抓狂。“On fleek”通常用来形容某人的眉毛。对，为什么？为什么？为什么？因为眉毛现在是一个大潮流。如果你画得一手好眉，你就会显得很好看。所以这是现在要做的新事情。通常它是一个在它源于 Instagram 的。每当有人——我五分钟前才在某个人的 Instagram 上看到，
they had great eyebrows. They had obviously just penciled them in. And and all the comments were like um gee those eyebrows are on fleeeeg Extra ease. Oh like 12 ease at least more the ease the better All those likes and literal ease and extra ease might sometimes great on your nerves But my guess John McQuarter says the problem might be with you, not them. Language is a parade, and nobody sits at a parade wishing that everybody would stand still. John McQuadar is a professor of English and comparative literature at Columbia University. He's also the author of a new book, Words on the Move, Why English, Won't, and Can't Sit Still, Like, Literally. So this is like literally hidden brain,
他们的眉毛画得很棒。很显然他们刚刚用眉笔画过。所有的评论都在说“天哪，那眉毛太精致了（on fleeeeg）”多加几个 e。哦，至少加了 12 个 e，e 越多越好。所有这些点赞和字面意义上的额外的 e，有时可能会让你感到恼火。但我的嘉宾约翰·麦克沃特（John McWhorter）说，问题可能出在你身上，而不是他们身上。语言是一场游行，没有人会坐在游行队伍中希望所有人都停在原地不动。约翰·麦克沃特是哥伦比亚大学的英语和比较文学教授。他也是一本新书的作者，书名为《正在流动的词语：为什么英语不会、也不能停滞不前，真的》（Words on the Move, Why English Won't, and Can't Sit Still, Like, Literally）。所以这就像是隐性大脑（hidden brain），
and I'm Shankar Vedantam. This week's episode is going to be lit, it's going to be turned, and it's going to be on fleek. We hope it's not going to be ratchet. We hope it's not going to be ratchet. John McWater, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you. Many of us have dictionaries at home or at work, John, and you say that dictionaries in some ways paint an unrealistic portrait of a language. They give us a sense that the meanings of words are fixed when in fact they're not. Yeah, dictionaries are wonderful things, but they create an illusion that there's such thing as a language that stands still. When really, it's the nature of human language to change. Each generation hears things and interprets things slightly differently from the previous one. And I mean, just in terms of even sounds changing in the way that you put words together
我是香卡·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。本周的节目会很火（lit），会很嗨（turned），而且会很精致（on fleek）。我们希望它不会变得很糟糕（ratchet）。我们希望它不会变得很糟糕（ratchet）。约翰·麦克沃特，欢迎来到《隐性大脑》。谢谢。约翰，我们许多人在家里或工作场所都有字典，而你却说字典在某些方面描绘了一幅不切实际的语言画像。它们给我们一种错觉，即词义是固定不变的，而事实上并非如此。对，字典是好东西，但它们造成了一种错觉，即存在一种停滞不前的语言。然而实际上，人类语言的本质就是改变。每一代人听到和解读事物的方式都与前一代人略有不同。我的意思是，仅仅就发音的改变而言，以及你把词语组合在一起的方式
changing bit by bit. And there's never been a language that didn't do that. I love this analogy you have in the book where you mention how, you know, thinking that a word has only one meaning is like looking at a snapshot taken at one point in a person's life and saying, this photograph represents the entirety of what this person looks like. Exactly. It's as if you saw a person, I'm not going to say it for, because then the person is growing up, and if I use that analogy, then it seems like I'm saying that language grows up, or it moves towards something,
也在一点一点地改变。而且从来没有哪种语言不这样做。我非常喜欢你在书中的这个比喻，你提到，你知道，认为一个词只有一个意思，就像看着一个人在生命某个阶段拍摄的快照，然后说，这张照片代表了这个人的全部长相。完全正确。这就好像你看到一个人——我不会直说，因为那样这个人就在长大，如果我用那个比喻，那么似乎我是在说语言在长大，或者它在朝某个方向发展，
or it develops. Imagine you meet somebody, they're 39, and you take their picture picture and then 10 years later when they're 49 you say, well that picture of you at 39 is what you really are and whatever has happened to you since then is some sort of disaster, something that shouldn't have happened. How come you aren't exactly the way you were 10 years ago? That's the way words are too. But it's so hard to feel that.
或者它在进化。想象一下你遇到了某个人，他们 39 岁，你给他们拍了张照片，然后 10 年后当他们 49 岁时你说，嗯，你 39 岁时的那张照片才是真正的你，从那以后发生在你身上的任何事都是某种灾难，是不应该发生的事情。你怎么不像 10 年前一模一样呢？词语也是这样的。但这种感觉很难体会。
Partly because our brains are on writing, as I say, in the book. We can't help as literate people thinking that the real language is something that sits still with letters written all nice and pretty on a page that can exist for hundreds of years. But that's not what language has ever been. Only a couple hundred languages.
部分原因正如我在书中说的，我们的思维受制于书面文字。作为识字的人，我们情不自禁地认为真正的语言是那种静止不动的东西，字母写得整整齐齐、漂漂亮亮地印在纸上，可以存在几百年。但语言从来都不是这样的。只有几百种语言——
If you want to be conservative about it, a hundred languages are written in any real way. And then there are 6,800 others. Language is something that's spoken, and spoken language, especially always keeps changing. It's inherent. One of the points you make in the book, of course, is that the evolution of words in their meanings is what gives us this flowering of hundreds or thousands of languages, is that the evolution of words in their meanings is what gives us this flowering of hundreds or thousands of languages, mistakes and errors, are what turned Latin into French. Yes, that's exactly true. What we think of today as a word undergoing some odd development
如果你想保守一点的话，有一百种语言是以真正的方式书写的。然后还有 6,800 种其他语言。语言是说出来的东西，而口语，尤其是口语，一直在不断变化。这是其固有的属性。你在书中提出的观点之一，当然是词语及其含义的演变，正是这种演变赋予了我们成百上千种语言的繁荣，正是这种演变赋予了我们成百上千种语言的繁荣，失误和错误，将拉丁语变成了法语。是的，这完全正确。我们今天认为正在经历某种奇怪发展的词
or people using some new construction is exactly how Latin turned into French. It's exactly how old English turned into modern English. And I don't think any of us are thinking that it's a shame that we're not using the language of Bayo Wolf. So I think that nobody would say that they don't think language should change. But what most people mean is that there'll be slang, that there'll be new words for new things, and that some of those words will probably come from other languages.
或者人们使用某种新结构，正是拉丁语变成法语的方式。这也是古英语变成现代英语的方式。我想我们没有人会觉得我们没有使用《贝奥武夫》（Beowulf）的语言是一种遗憾。所以我想没有人会说他们认为语言不应该改变。但大多数人的意思是，会有俚语，会有新词来表达新事物，其中一些词可能会来自其他语言。
But I don't think that it's always clear to us that language has to change in that things are going to come in, that we're going to hear as intrusions or as irritating or as mistakes. Despite the fact that that's how you get from, say, old person to modern person, and nobody wishes that we hadn't developed our modern languages today from the ancient versions. I want to talk in the second half of our conversation about why the meanings of words change but I want to start by talking about how they change. Let's start with the word literally. It turns out as you point out that in common usage literally literally means the
但我认为我们并不总是清楚，语言必须改变，有些东西会融入进来，我们会将其视为入侵、恼人或错误。尽管事实是通过这种方式，比如说，从古代人演变到了现代人，没有人希望我们今天的现代语言没有从古代版本演变而来。我想在对话的后半部分谈谈为什么词语的含义会改变，但我想先谈谈它们是如何改变的。让我们从“literally”（字面意思/简直）这个词开始。正如你所指出的，在日常用法中，“literally”实际上意味着
opposite of literally. The second button literally makes our breaks the shirt. Look at it. It's too high. Dr. Harris, you are literally the meanest person I have ever met. In the first days, literally the first day, literally stupid, literally making... We're literally unfiguratively, literally... Yeah, and it irritates people. But there's a different way of seeing, literally. If you take literally in what we can think of as it's earliest meaning,
“literally”的反义词。这件衬衫的第二个扣子简直（literally）要了我的命/毁了这件衬衫。你看。它太高了。哈里斯博士，你简直（literally）是我见过最坏的人。在最初的日子里，简直（literally）就是第一天，简直（literally）蠢透了，简直（literally）在制造……我们简直是（literally）而非比喻地，简直……是的，这很惹人厌烦。但有一种看待“literally”的不同方式。如果你把“literally”理解为我们可以认为的最早含义，
the earliest meaning known to us is by the letter. And so somebody says something literally. Somebody takes a point literally. Well, if you have a word like that and if it's an intensifier of that kind, you can almost guess that literally is going to come to mean something more like just really. So what happens is that once literally comes to feel like it means really, people start using it in figurative constructions such as I with literally dying of thirst. Now many people hear that and they think,
我们所知的最早含义是“逐字地”。所以有人说“literally”某事。有人“literally”地理解某个观点。好吧，如果你有这样一个词，如果它是这种程度的修饰语，你几乎可以猜到，“literally”最终会变得更像是“真的（really）”的意思。所以发生的情况是，一旦“literally”让人觉得它的意思是“真的（really）”，人们就开始在比喻结构中使用它，比如“我简直（literally）快渴死了”。现在很多人听到这话就会想，
well, that's no good because now literally can mean it's opposite. But we have plenty of words like that in English where it doesn't bother us at all. For example, if you take seeds and put them in the ground, that's one thing. But if you see the watermelon, nobody assumes that you're taking seeds and putting them in the watermelon, you're taking them out. Those are called contrainins and literally has become a new contrainim. It should be thought of as fun.
嗯，这可不好，因为现在“literally”可以意味着它的反义词了。但在英语中我们有很多这样的词，它们一点也不困扰我们。例如，如果你把种子放进土里，那是一回事。但是如果你“see（看见/剥去）”西瓜，没有人会假设你把种子放进西瓜里，你是把它们拿出来。这些被称为反义同义词（contronym），而“literally”已经成为一个新的反义同义词。它应该被认为是一种乐趣。
So you make the case that the meanings of words change all the time. It's a bold argument that we should in some ways welcome it when people do their own thing. But I have to say, I noticed that you had a book out a few years ago that seemed to say the opposite. And it was titled, Doing Our Own Thing, The Decredation of Language and Music, and why we should like care. Does the New John McQuater have a disagreement with the Old John McQuater?
所以你提出这样的观点：词语的含义一直在改变。这是一个很大胆的论点，即我们在某种程度上应该欢迎人们按自己的方式行事。但我不得不说，我注意到你几年前出过一本书，似乎在表达相反的观点。书名为《各行其是：语言与音乐的退化，以及我们为什么应该关心》（Doing Our Own Thing, The Decredation of Language and Music, and why we should like care）。新约翰·麦克沃特与老约翰·麦克沃特有分歧吗？
That's a very rich question. And you know, it's given to the point where I've been in the business a while and there are Decisions I made back in my relicking 30s, which I wouldn't make now and doing our own thing was one where I allowed a Subtitle that I shouldn't have because the publisher thought that that would make it sell better and I think it did But that book wasn't really about the degradation of language and music. To this day, I hear sometimes that I've written somewhere that rap is terrible music and that it makes people pull their pants down and kill each other. And I think a lot of it is because of just the music in that subtitle, when actually I didn't say anything like that. Actually, a lot of people really hated that book.
这是一个非常丰富的问题。你知道，这让我回想起我已经在这个行业混了一段时间了，我在年少轻狂的 30 岁时做出了一些决定，如果现在我是不会那样做了，《各行其是》就是其中之一，当时我允许了一个我不该用的副标题，因为出版商认为那样能让它更好卖，我想确实如此。但那本书并不是真正关于语言和音乐的退化的。直到今天，我有时还会听到有人说我曾在某处写过说唱是糟糕的音乐，它让人脱下裤子自相残杀。我想这很大程度上是因为那个副标题里的那些音乐字眼，而实际上我根本没说过那样的话。事实上，很多人真的很讨厌那本书。
That book disappointed a lot of people who thought they were going to get something like Lintrust's each shoots and leaves. I never wrote such a book and their people mad at me to this day for tricking them by allowing that subtitle. One of the things I found really interesting is that the evolution of words and language is constant. So, new words are as likely to evolve as old ones. So, LOL was an internet abbreviation, meaning laugh out loud or laughing out loud, but LOL and common
那本书让许多人感到失望，他们以为自己会看到类似林恩·特鲁斯（Lynne Truss）的《吃、射与留》（Eats, Shoots & Leaves）那样的书。我从来没有写过这样的书，直到今天还有人对我很生气，因为我允许使用那个副标题来愚弄了他们。我发现非常有趣的一点是，词语和语言的演变是持续不断的。因此，新词和旧词一样有可能发生演变。所以，LOL 是一个互联网缩写，意思是“大声笑（laugh out loud）”或“大声笑着”，但在当今的日常用法中，
usage today doesn't necessarily mean historical laughter. No, because LOL was an expression, it was a piece of language, and so you knew that its meaning was going to change. The only question was in which way. And then ended up becoming less direct reflection of hearty laughter than an indication of the kind of almost subconscious laughter that we do in any kind of conversation that's meant as friendly. It can be almost counterintuitive to listen to how much giggling and laughing you do. In ordinary, actually rather plain exchanges with people, it's part of a general running indication that everything's okay between you and the other person, just like
LOL 并不一定意味着历史上的大笑。不，因为 LOL 是一个表达方式，它是语言的一部分，所以你知道它的含义会发生改变。唯一的悬念是以什么方式改变。最终它变成了一个不那么直接反映开怀大笑的标志，而是变成了一种几乎是潜意识里的笑的暗示，这种笑我们在任何旨在友好的对话中都会有。听到自己发出多少咯咯的笑声和笑声，有时可能会违背直觉。在普通、甚至相当平淡的交流中，它是整体持续暗示的一部分，表明你和对方之间一切都好，就像
one's expected to smile a little bit in most interactions. So, LOL starts out as meaning hardy, hardy, hard hard. But then, it becomes something more abstract. But the reason that it seems so elusive is because we don't really think about the quote-unquote meaning of things like, our conversation easing laughter. We actually also heard this idea from the students Maggie talked to in Washington. We make fun of people who use LOL and text messages, but I see that I'm using it more than ever, but more in a sassy way. So if my roommate were to say something long lines of, can I have the room from 10 to 12
在大多数互动中，人们被期望微微一笑一样。所以，LOL 一开始的意思是哈哈大笑、大笑、狂笑。但随后，它变得更加抽象。但它之所以显得如此难以捉摸，是因为我们并没有真正去思考诸如“我们的对话舒缓了笑声”这类的所谓“含义”。实际上，我们也从玛吉在华盛顿采访的学生那里听到了这个想法。我们会取笑在短信中使用 LOL 的人，但我发现我比以往任何时候都更多地使用它，但更多是带有一点俏皮的语气。所以如果我的室友说类似这样的话：“我能从 10 点到 12 点用一下房间吗，
and I'm trying to take a nap, I'll be like, LOL, no. So just to kind of ease it, like ease the hit of the rejection. As someone who spends a lot of his time listening to language evolve, John hears a lot of slang. He's a defender of language on the move, but I wanted to know if there were things that irritated even him. Oh yeah, I'm a human being, and so even though I insist that there is no scientific basis for rejecting some new word or some new meaning or some new construction. I certainly have my visceral biases. And so for example, can I get a hamburger? Can I get some chicken? I've always found that a very grating way to ask for something at a store.
我想睡个午觉”，我就会说：“LOL，不行。”所以只是为了缓和一下，就像缓和拒绝带来的打击一样。作为把大量时间花在聆听语言演变上的人，约翰听到了许多俚语。他是流动的语言的捍卫者，但我想知道是否有连他也会感到恼火的事情。哦，是的，我是个人，所以尽管我坚决主张拒绝某个新词、某个新含义或某个新结构是没有科学依据的。我当然也有我本能的偏见。比如，例如，“Can I get a hamburger?（我能拿个汉堡吗？）”“Can I get some chicken?（我能来点鸡肉吗？）”我一直觉得在商店里用这种方式点东西非常刺耳。
It seems kind of elliptical. Would it be possible that I obtained? And then if you are going to be that elliptical, why use the casual word get? And it sounds a little bit abrupt and grabby like you're going to get something instead of being given. All of these are very subjective things. It's not necessarily may I please have, but may I have, I'll have, but not can I get a,
这似乎有点省略。难道是“Would it be possible that I obtained?（我获得……是否可能？）”？既然你要用这么省略的表达，为什么要用“get”这个随意的词呢？这听起来有点唐突和贪婪，就像你要去拿（get）什么东西，而不是被给予（given）。所有这些都是非常主观的事情。不一定非得是“may I please have（我能否拥有）”，而是“may I have（我可以要吗）”、“I'll have（我要）”，但绝不是“can I get a（我能拿一个……吗）”。
I find it just vulgar for reasons that as you can see, I can't even do what I would call defending. It's just how I feel. And we're all gonna have feelings like that. And when I listen to people having their peas, I don't think, stop it. But what I am thinking is, you should realize that even if you don't like it, there's nothing wrong with it in the long run. Because, for example, Jonathan
我只是觉得这很粗俗，原因正如你所看到的，我甚至无法进行我所谓的辩护。这只是我的感觉。我们所有人都会有这种感觉。当我听到人们发出他们的“p”音时，我想的不是：住手。但我心里想的是：你应该意识到，即使你不喜欢它，从长远来看它也没有任何问题。因为，例如，乔纳森·斯威夫特（Jonathan Swift）
Swift didn't like it that people were saying, kissed instead of kiss it, and rebuked instead of rebuked. He didn't like that people were shortening the words. How does that sound now? We don't want to be like that. Alright, I think it might be time for me to confess one of my pet peeves that has to do with the word momentarily. Growing up, I understood this word to mean for a very short time, as in John McQuatter was momentarily surprised. But I find that people now usually use the word to mean very soon, as in we're going to board the plane momentarily. The dictionary says both uses are correct.
不喜欢人们说“kissed”而不是“kissed”（译注：原文此处涉及英文过去式发音或拼写变化，此处保持原意），不喜欢人们说“rebuked”而不是其他形式。他不喜欢人们把词缩短。现在听起来怎么样？我们不想成为那样的人。好吧，我想现在也许是我承认我的一大烦恼的时候了，这个烦恼与“momentarily”（片刻/一会儿）这个词有关。在我成长过程中，我理解这个词的意思是非常短的一段时间，比如“约翰·麦克沃特感到片刻的惊讶”。但我发现人们现在通常用这个词来表示“很快”，比如“我们马上就要登机了（momentarily）”。字典上说这两种用法都是正确的。
But you know John something nauseate me every time I hear the word used wrong. And after listening to you I realize I might have to finally give in. When we come back I'm going to ask you about why languages change and whether there are hidden rules at shape why some words are more likely to evolve than others. We'll be back momentarily. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. John, you've noted that humans have been using language for tens of thousands of years, but for most of that time, language was talking. Writing came along relatively recently. Are the spoken origins of language one reason that words are so often on the move?
但你知道吗，约翰，每次听到这个词被误用，我都感到一阵恶心。听了你的话，我意识到我可能不得不最终妥协了。稍后回来，我将问你为什么语言会改变，以及是否存在一些隐藏的规则，决定了为什么某些词比其他词更有可能演变。我们一会儿就回来。请继续收听。这里是《隐性大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。约翰，你曾指出人类使用语言已有数万年之久，但在绝大多数时间里，语言都是靠说的。书面文字的出现相对较晚。语言的口头起源是词语总是不断流动的原因之一吗？
Yes, Shankar, that's exactly it. Language, as it evolved, was just talking to an extent that can be very hard for we literate people to imagine. There was no way of transcribing an approximation of what people said and nobody would have thought of doing it. Language was talk. When language was like that, of course, it changed a lot. Fast, because once you said it, it was gone, and if people heard the sounds a little differently, and produced them a little differently, if there were new meanings of words very quickly, whatever the original meaning was, wouldn't be remembered. There was no such thing as looking up what it originally meant. And so language changed, just like the clouds in the sky,
是的，香卡，正是如此。语言在演变过程中，仅仅是通过说话的形式存在的，这种程度可能是我们这些识字的人很难想象的。当时没有办法转录人们所说话语的近似值，也没有人会想到去这样做。语言就是交谈。当语言是这样的时候，它当然会发生很大变化。而且变化很快，因为一旦你把它说出口，它就消失了；如果人们对声音的理解略有不同，发音也略有不同，如果词语的含义很快发生了新的变化，无论最初的含义是什么，都不会被人们记住。当时根本没有去查阅它最初意思这回事。所以语言改变了，就像天上的云彩一样，
but then you start writing things down down and you're in a whole new land. Because once things are sitting there written on that piece of paper, there's that illusion. And it really is an illusion that what language is is something that sits still. There's a way of speaking right. And the way you speak right is not by speaking the way the people around you in your life speak, but by speaking the way the language is, as it sits there all nice and pretty on that piece of paper where its reality exists. Would it be possible to use what we have learned about how words and languages evolve to potentially write what a dictionary might look like in 50 years or 100 years?
但后来你开始把事情写下来，你就进入了一片全新的土地。因为一旦东西静静地写在那张纸上，就会产生一种错觉。这确实是一种错觉，即语言是一个静止不动的东西。有一种正确的说话方式。而正确说话的方式，不是像你生活中周围的人那样说话，而是像语言本身那样说话，当它静静地、漂漂亮亮地存在于那张纸上，展现其真实存在时那样。我们能否利用我们对词语和语言演变规律的了解，来推测一下 50 年后或 100 年后的字典会是什么样子？
You could have fun doing such a thing. The fact is that language change can always go in one of many directions as a chance element to it. So you can't know how the words are going to come out, but you can take good guesses. Endings are going to tend to drop off. So if you took a bunch of those tendencies, you could make up, say, the English of 50 years from now. But some of the things would just be complete chance. You would never know, for example, that,
你可以通过做这样的事情来寻找乐趣。事实是，语言的改变总是可以朝多个方向发展，其中包含随机的因素。所以你无法确切知道词语最终会变成什么样，但你可以做出很好的猜测。词尾往往会脱落。因此，如果你借鉴其中一堆趋势，你就可以拼凑出，比如说，50 年后的英语。但有些事情将完全是纯粹的偶然。例如，你永远不会知道——
give you an example I've actually been thinking about. Women under about 30 in the United States, when they're excited or they're trying to underline a point, putting up at the end of things. And so somebody will say, well, who was it who you thought was going to give you this present? You were! And I mean, really, it sounds exactly like that.
举一个我一直在思考的例子。美国 30 岁以下的女性，当她们感到兴奋或者试图强调某个观点时，会在句尾加上一个“up”。所以有人会说：“Well, who was it who you thought was going to give you this present? You were!（哦，你以为是谁要送你这个礼物？就是你！）”我的意思是，真的，听起来完全就是这样。
I know was there, or something along the lines of, babe! And as odd as that sounds, I can guarantee you if you watch any TV show with women under a certain age, or if you just go out on an American street and listen, you'll find that that's a new kind of exclamatory particle. That is the most random thing, and I would really guess that in a few decades, men will be doing it too, those sorts of things tend to start with women. You couldn't have predicted this. I know, move! You can't know, but you can certainly know that if we could listen to people 50 years from now, they'd sound odd.
我知道在那儿，或者类似“宝贝（babe）！”这样的话。尽管听起来很奇怪，但我向你保证，如果你看任何由特定年龄以下的女性出演的电视节目，或者你只是走到美国街头去听一听，你会发现这是一种新型的感叹助词。这是最随机的事情，我真的猜想在几十年后，男性也会开始这样说，这类事情往往是从女性开始的。你根本无法预测这一点。我知道，走开！你无法预知，但你当然可以肯定的是，如果我们能听到 50 年后的人说话，他们听起来会很奇怪。
Something new will have started by then. Just like if we listen to people in 1971, they sound odd in that they don't say like, as much as we do. That hasn't started then. Imagine how we would sound to them if they could hear us. Well, if you're so upset about it, maybe you can think of a way to help her. Right.
到那时，某些新的东西已经开始了。就像如果我们听 1971 年的人说话，他们听起来也很奇怪，因为他们不像我们这样频繁地使用“like（像/那个）”。那时候这还没开始呢。想象一下，如果他们能听到我们说话，我们在他们听来会是什么样。好吧，如果你对此这么生气，也许你能想出一个办法来帮她。对。
You know, lots of people blow off steam about something they think is wrong, but very few people are willing to get involved and do something about it. I'm willing to get involved. So all this raises a really interesting question. You know, we spend years teaching children about how to use language correctly.
你知道，很多人会对他们认为错误的事情大发牢骚，但极少有人愿意卷入其中并采取实际行动。我愿意参与其中。所以这一切提出了一个非常有趣的问题。你知道，我们花了好几年时间教导儿童如何正确使用语言。
As someone who works in media, I often find that people who can write well are often people who know how to think well. So I often equate clarity of writing with clarity of thought. How do you balance the imperative of teaching correct usage, which I think is probably important, with the reality that this edifice that you're teaching is constantly crumbling. It's a matter of fashion, pure and simple. People do need to be taught what the socially acceptable forms are. But what we should teach is not that the good way is logical and the way that you're comfortable doing it is illogical. It should just be, here is the natural way. Then there's some things that you're supposed to do in public because that's the way it is, whether it's fair or not.
作为一名媒体工作者，我经常发现，擅长写作的人往往也是懂得如何思考的人。所以我经常将文字表达的清晰度等同于思维的清晰度。你如何平衡教授正确用法的必要性——我认为这可能很重要——与你所传授的这座大厦正在不断崩塌这一现实？这纯粹是一个时尚问题。人们确实需要被教导什么是社会可接受的形式。但我们应该教给他们的不应该是：好的方式是合乎逻辑的，而你习惯的方式是不合逻辑的。而应该仅仅是：这是自然的方式。然后有些事情是你本应在公众场合做的，因为事情就是这样，无论这是否公平。
You can even teach people to have a little bit of fun with the artifice, but it's exactly like, it was maybe about 20 years ago, that somebody, a girlfriend I had told me that, if I wore pants that had little vertical pleats up near the waist, then I was conveying that I was kind of past it. That was somehow a dad's fashion and that I should start wearing flat fronted pants. That is utterly arbitrary that those little slits in American society look elderly.
你甚至可以教人们对这种人为的规则觉得有点好笑，但这完全就像，大概 20 年前，我的一位女朋友告诉我，如果我穿腰部附近有小垂直褶皱的裤子，就是在传达我已经过时了的信号。那不知怎么的成了爸爸的时尚，我应该开始穿平腰（flat fronted）裤子。在美国社会中，那些小褶皱看起来显老，这完全是任意的。
But for various chance reasons, that's what those slits came to mean. So I started wearing flat fronted pants. That is exactly why you should say fewer books instead of less books in some situations. And yes, Billy and I went to the store rather than the perfectly natural Billy and me went to the store. Sometimes you just have to suck it up.
但由于各种偶然的原因，这些褶皱就变成了那个意思。所以我开始穿平腰裤子。这就是为什么你在某些情况下应该说“fewer books”而不是“less books”的原因。是的，“Billy and me went to the store（比利和我都去了商店）”完全很自然，但正确的却是“Billy and I went to the store”。有时你只能默默承受。
But I think that we should learn not to listen to people using natural language as committing errors, because there's no such thing as making a mistake in your language if a critical mass of other people speaking your language are doing the same thing. You make the case that concerns over the misuse of language might actually be one of the last places where people can publicly express prejudice and class differences. And as you point out, it's not just that people feel that a word is being misused, they often feel angry about it. And you think this anger is actually telling.
但我认为我们应该学会不要把使用自然语言的人视为在犯错误，因为如果使用你语言的大多数人都在做同样的事情，那么在你的语言中根本就没有犯错这回事。你提出这样的观点：对误用语言的担忧实际上可能是人们公开表达偏见和阶级差异的最后阵地之一。正如你所指出的，人们不仅觉得一个词被误用了，他们往往还对此感到愤怒。你认为这种愤怒实际上说明了问题。
Yeah, I really do. I think that the tone that many people use when they're complaining that somebody says, Billy and me went to the store, is a little bit in commensurate with the significance of the issue. And I can't help surmising that part of it is that the educated American has been taught and often well that you're not supposed to look down on people because of gender, because of race, because of ability.
是的，我确实这么认为。我认为许多人在抱怨别人说“Billy and me went to the store”时所使用的语气，与问题的重要性有点不相称。我不禁猜测，部分原因在于受过教育的美国人接受过教育，而且往往受过良好的教育，即你不应该因为性别、种族、能力而看不起别人。
But might we allow that there's probably a part of all human beings that wants to look down on somebody else? What a cynical thing to say, but that doesn't mean that it might not be true. And if that is true, then the educated person can look down on people who say, Billy and me went to the store or who are using literally quote unquote wrong and condemn them in the kinds of terms that once were ordinary for condemning black people
但我们是否可以承认，所有人类内心深处可能都有一部分想要看不起别人？这是多么愤世嫉俗的说法，但这并不意味着它不可能是真的。如果这是真的，那么受过教育的人就可以看不起那些说“Billy and me went to the store”的人，或者看不起那些“literally”引号里用错的人，并用曾经用来谴责黑人
or women or what have you. So I just think that it's something we need to check ourselves for. It might irritate you slightly to hear somebody say something like I need less books instead of fewer books, but does a person who says that really deserve the kind of sneering condemnation that you often see? Something's off. And I think it's because there's a lowly or part of our nature that grammar allows us to vent in the absence of other ways to do it that have not been available for some decades for a lot of us. One of the ultimate messages I
或女性或诸如此类的言辞来谴责他们。所以我只是觉得这是我们需要反省自己的地方。听到有人说“我需要 less books 而不是 fewer books”可能会让你觉得有点恼火，但说这句话的人真的配得上你经常看到的那些冷嘲热讽的谴责吗？有点不对劲。我认为这是因为语法允许我们在没有其他途径的情况下，发泄我们天性中较为低劣的一部分，而这种宣泄途径对我们许多人来说已经有几十年不具备了。我从你的工作中
took from your work is that, you know, we can choose to have languages that are alive or languages that are dead and dead languages never change. And some of us might prefer those but if you prefer life the unpredictability of life then living languages in many ways are much more fun. Language is a parade and nobody sits at a parade wishing that everybody would stand still. If the language stayed the way it was it would be like a pressed flower in a book or as I say, I think it would be like some inflatable doll rather than a person. I think that it's better to think of language as a parade, that either you're watching or
汲取到的终极信息之一是，我们可以选择拥有活的语言或死的语言，而死的语言永远不会改变。我们中的一些人可能更喜欢死语言，但如果你更喜欢生命、喜欢生命中不可预测性，那么在许多方面，活的语言要有趣得多。语言是一场游行，没有人会坐在游行队伍中希望所有人都停在原地不动。如果语言保持原样，它就会像书本里压扁的花，或者正如我所说，我认为它会像某种充气娃娃，而不是一个活生生的人。我认为最好把语言想象成一场游行，要么你在观看，
frankly, that you're in, especially because the people are never going to stand still. It's never happened, it's never going to. And if you can enjoy it as a parade, instead of wondering why people keep walking instead of just sitting on chairs and blowing on their tubas and not moving, then you have more fun. I want everybody to have the fun I'm having.
坦白说，要么你就在其中，特别是永远不会有人停在原地。这从未发生过，也永远不会发生。如果你能把它当成一场游行来欣赏，而不是去纳闷为什么人们一直在走，而不是坐在椅子上吹着他们的图巴号却一动不动，那么你就会觉得更有趣。我希望每个人都能体验到我所感受到的乐趣。
John McQuatter, thank you so much for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you for having me, Sunker. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Maggie Penman. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Renee Clour, and our supervising producer Tara Boyle. This week we also want to welcome two new people to our team, our new producer, Raina Cohen, and our spring intern Chloe Connelly. We're excited to have them on board.
约翰·麦克沃特，非常感谢你今天来到《隐性大脑》。谢谢你邀请我，香卡。本期《隐性大脑》由玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）制作。我们的团队成员包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、蕾妮·克劳尔（Renee Clour）以及我们的监督制片人塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）。本周我们还要欢迎两位新成员加入我们的团队，我们的新制片人雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）和我们的春季实习生克洛伊·康利（Chloe Connelly）。我们很高兴他们的加入。
Our Ranzang hero this week is Casey Herman. Casey's a producer on how I built this and the Ted Radio Hour. In a former life, he walked in IT, which is something he never should have told his colleagues. We now bombard him with computer questions. Casey always has a friendly ear if he want to run an idea by someone smart. Casey, thanks for all the help. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station.
我们本周的 Ranzang 英雄是凯西·赫尔曼（Casey Herman）。凯西是《我是如何做到的》（How I Built This）和《泰德广播小时》（Ted Radio Hour）的制片人。在过去的生活中，他从事过 IT 工作，这是他绝不应该告诉同事的事情。我们现在用电脑问题狂轰滥炸他。如果你想跟一个聪明的人探讨一个想法，凯西总是愿意倾听的朋友。凯西，谢谢你所有的帮助。欲了解更多《隐性大脑》的内容，您可以在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上关注我们，并在当地的公共广播电台上收听我的故事。
If you liked this episode, please tell one friend who doesn't know about hidden brain about our show, and tell us on social media whom you've tapped. We're always looking for new people to find the show. We have another request for you. Have you ever considered making a dramatic change in the way you consume the news? Many people say they've changed how and how much they listen to the news after the 2016 presidential election. If you've ever made a big change in your news habits, we want to hear from you. Tell us what you've changed and how it's affected you. We might feature your story in an upcoming episode that looks at whether there are healthy and unhealthy ways to consume the news. Call and leave us
如果你喜欢这一期节目，请把我们节目推荐给一位不知道《隐性大脑》的朋友，并在社交媒体上告诉我们你向谁推荐了。我们一直在寻找新听众来发现这个节目。我们还有一个请求。你是否曾考虑过在获取新闻的方式上做出重大改变？许多人说他们在 2016 年总统大选后改变了收听新闻的方式和数量。如果你曾对自己的新闻收听习惯做出过重大改变，我们想听听你的故事。告诉我们你改变了什么以及它对你产生了什么影响。我们可能会在即将播出的一期节目中展示你的故事，探讨获取新闻的方式是否有健康与不健康之分。请致电给我们
a message at 661-772-7246. That 661-778-brain. I'm Shankar Vedanthan and this is NPR. I'm going to some early, so I hear everything. This is a new up and coming one, so be ready. LMK is something people used to say in text. Yeah, let me know. But now everybody goes, she was really wearing that, let me know. But now everybody goes, is she really wearing that? Let me know.
留言，电话号码是 661-772-7246。即 661-778-brain。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，这是 NPR。我要早点去，所以我什么都能听到。这是一个新兴的词，所以要准备好。LMK 是人们以前在短信中常说的话。对，let me know（告诉我）。但现在每个人都说：“她真的穿那个吗，let me know。”但现在每个人都说，“她真的穿那个吗？告诉我。”
Or like, LMK. Whoa. Yeah. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者像 LMK。哇。是的。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。